she's only 17 years old but she's
already blazing her own path
and spreading cheer and strength along
the way
caitlyn thrash is a cheerleader by day
and a firefighter by night
she is a true wild flower she's
here please welcome caitlin thrash
how are you i'm good how are you oh my
goodness i'm
so happy that you're here
so caitlyn what like inspired the
firefighter aspect well my
my neighbor is one of our chiefs and
then my other neighbor is an ex-chief
so i mean i would see them leaving all
the time for calls
when i was younger and then one night
like
two or three years ago they're like we
have a junior program
at our fire department i was like oh
like okay like that's cool
um and after the very first class i was
like this is amazing i need to continue
this and then
two years later now i'm an active member
of the fire department
[Applause]
as the mother of two daughters my jaw is
on the floor
well it's prom season and
um have you been prepping it all um
honestly no
well can we think with you of course
can we do absolutely could we do like a
whole
transformation during the hour of the
show yeah definitely
really yes
i do come from movies and one thing we
all love in movies whether you're making
them or watching them is a makeover
am i right oh yeah okay great because
you put the wild and wildflower but
we're still flowers and girls so
let's do a movie makeover all right
sounds good thank you
i'm so excited all right this will all
take place in the next 60 minutes and
we're gonna check
in with you throughout the show okay now
you go backstage and start your process
and then i'll check in with you
throughout the hour all right thank you
so much
throughout the show we are following a
prom makeover on our guest
caitlyn thrash who is an amazing young
woman
she is a cheerleader oh and also a
firefighter
she is a true wildflower as we say it on
this show and prom is all about the
truth
okay well we're gonna check in with them
now it's time to see her final look
okay here is caitlin before
and here is caitlin ready for the prom
now
[Applause]
how do you feel amazing
that's so pretty and i think you look so
lovely
thank you you really do you're so pretty
inside
and out i'm i don't know why but i just
feel so
proud of you because you know we all
want to be
strong women who like do something
wonderful in the world and that's what
you're doing
thank you i'm so impressed by you thank
you i appreciate it
okay all right well i love this dress
thank you so much to
sherry hill for this beautiful dress and
i can't think of a more beautiful person
that it is laying upon and
they're the one and only leading prom
and evening wear designers from
austin texas go austin one of my
favorite places
on the globe and i absolutely love them
and we couldn't let you have this
magical moment without
sharing it with the people closest to
you so we'd like to welcome some of your
closest friends
from your cheerleading squad and fire
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my stations
[Applause]
you show up for everybody else they want
to show up for you
i appreciate it what do you guys
[Applause]
oh think goodness do you feel confident
yes that i do i mean what is the
difference between
this type of confidence and being a
firefighter type of confidence
i know it takes a lot of confidence a
lot of courage to be a firefighter but
i feel pretty good right now
[Applause]
well that's having the best of both
worlds which you absolutely deserve and
i'm also just going to throw in a 500
gift certificate to make your prom
everything you want it to be and more
just so you have a little extra spending
money for any little odds and ends that
we didn't take care of here
um thank you caitlin i appreciate it
thank you so much
oh my goodness tell us how your problem
went
of course okay can you see some pictures
yes definitely
okay okay i can't let this go all right
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you to our vfs thank you to
caitlin's friends
your squad ladies and gentlemen
who you live with and support you right
back thanks for showing up guys
and have a wonderful day take this with
you thank you so much
[Music]